wenn man den titel dieses videos liest
dann denkt man an etwas wirklich neues
unglaubliches eine mission e so noch nie
gegeben hat
es ist aber ganz anders im mission hills
heute geht sensationell wurde aber vor
40 jahren gestartet und ist jetzt
unterwegs in die weiten des weltraums
außerhalb unseres sonnensystems
man erwarte jetzt wirklich zum zeitpunkt
hat willkommen
vor 40 jahren wurden die sonde voyager 1
und 2 gestartet wie lieferten ersten
scharfen bilder von jupiter und saturn
und weiter zwei dann noch von uranus und
neptun wurde dabei auf eine
geschwindigkeit von 60.000 kilometern
pro stunde beschleunigt inzwischen ist
die besonnene 20 milliarden kilometer
von uns entfernt die punkt signale
brauchen jetzt rund einen tag von ihr
zur erde wie ist jetzt bereits außerhalb
des kupfergürtels der übrigens rts jahre
1988 später durch eine
computersimulation bestätigt wurde am
start der sonde war noch vollkommen
unklar was sie in dieser entfernung
erwarten wird jetzt sind heute 1 also
ausweiten dieses letzten ringes wobei
noch weiter draußen die hort für wolke
vermutet wird wie wird als quelle für
kometen vermutlich dienst ohne diese
folge nämlich nicht geben könnte unser
sonnensystem ist so als ob alle hier
befindlichen kometen schon längst
verdampft sein müssten also muss es
diese woche gibt es aber bereits die
phase der walser interstellarer mission
erreicht wollte einfach nämlich die
heliosphäre verlassen
an der grenze nehmen die sonnenwinde ab
und vermischen sich mit der lokalen
interstellaren wolken
das ist eine ansammlung von
interstellare materie die durch die
sonnenwinde von unserem sonnensystem
abgehalten werden sie hat einen
durchmesser von rund 30 nicht jahren
wahnsinn unser sonnensystem passiert
diese wolke rund 100000 jahren und wird
den rund zehn mit 20.000 jahren
durchwanderten schwester runde der beute
ein sieger zwei konnte übrigens beim
durchgang der grenze an der heliopause
zu dieser interstellar wolke
detaillierte messungen machen
die beute einfach fehl schlugen jetzt
wissen wir dass der thermischen schock
an dieser ganze wie die wellen an einem
strand in not erster deutscher zwei hat
diese grenze nämlich fünf mal passiert
und wir wissen jetzt
heliosphäre der verfällt sondern durch
die sonne gebildet hat eine delle hat
die durch die interstellare wolke
verursacht wird auf jeden fall sind die
beiden sonnen auf dem weg in den
interstellaren raum zwischen den sonnen
und sternensysteme und heute eins ist
damit das am abstand weite von uns
entfernte objekt das sie von menschen
angefertigt wurde und es ist eine ganz
besondere anfertigung an bord sind
nämlich nicht nur wissenschaftliche
instrumente sondern auch botschaften an
außerirdische eine goldene schallplatte
wurde an der sonne montiert
außerirdische erfahren über diese die
position unseres sonnensystems werden
verschiedene grußworte und geräusche von
der erde und musik herzliche grüße an
alle
[Musik]
wenn also jemals außerirdische die
sonder aufspüren sollten ja dann werden
wir uns finden uns ja wie wenn man sehen
ob diesen hawking recht oder unrecht
hatte mit seinen befürchtungen 40.000
jahren wird heute 1 1 stern erreichen
platz steht im sternbild albert wenn es
dort einen entwickelten bewohnten
planeten geben sollte hätten dessen
bewohner die chance etwas über uns
erfahren wenn sie in der lage sind einen
plattenspieler zu bauen
die bauanleitung für ein plattenspieler
ist nämlich auch mit an bord den muss
man nicht bauen um die beiden schweizer
gehören ich will auf jeden fall
wahnsinnig spannend was alles so bei
raumfahrtmissionen herausgefunden wird
und heute eins und zwei sind ja noch
eine weile unterwegs und werden noch für
eine weile energie habe ich so viele
jahre binz unfair wenn er das spannend
findet und auch weitere themen
beispielsweise entwicklung drückt mir
hier ein abo auf auge einfach
draufklicken vergesst nicht danach mehr
einen auf league locker zugehen
ansonsten gesagt platz